hablaremos ahora sobre el índice de masa
corporal qué es esto cómo se calcula
quiénes lo usamos o no y lo habríamos
así para esto le pediremos a un señor
vamos a hacer este señor de palitos
vamos a pedirle al señor de palitos que
se suben una báscula y con ello
tendremos su peso más adelante le
podremos preguntar si no le molesta que
tomemos su altura
y con esto tendremos un par de datos
peso y altura el índice de masa corporal
mide la relación entre ambos y se
calcula de la siguiente manera peso
sobre altura al cuadrado
donde el peso se mide en kilogramos y la
altura en metros
como vamos a sacar esta relación si yo
quisiera sacar mi índice de masa
corporal haré lo siguiente tengo mi peso
que lo conozco que ahora es 56.5
kilogramos y la altura la altura que
actualmente tengo es 160 como lo vamos a
calcular vamos entonces al índice de
masa corporal colocaré mi peso mis 56.5
kilogramos sobre 1.6 metros por 1.6
metros
a mí por cuestiones prácticas me gusta
hacer como las operaciones
paso a paso entonces 56 puntos y 56
puntos 5 kilogramos lo pondré sobre 1.6
por 1.6 es igual a 2.56 metros ok ahora
hagamos la división si yo pongo en la
calculadora 56.5 kilogramos y lo divido
entre 2 puntos 56 me dará un número 22
ese es mi índice de masa corporal 22 y
está padrísimo y está genial y me
encanta y está increíble pero qué
significan no sé realmente qué significa
ese 22
los doctores y los nutriólogos han hecho
la siguiente tabla
tenemos una tabla que va del 0 al 30 o
más ya veremos cómo va calculemos que
por aquí está el 18.5
y más o menos el 25 se encuentra por
aquí
cualquier persona que tenga un índice de
masa corporal entre el 0 y el 18.5 lo
colocamos en naranja
y esto indica que están bajos de peso es
decir que aún les falta el peso por
llegar de acuerdo a su altura de
preferencia que sea músculo obviamente
entre el 18.5 y el 25 lo pondremos en
color azul y esta es la zona de mayor
salud la pondremos con una carita feliz
y más allá del 25 digamos entre el 25 y
el 30 colocaremos en un naranja mucho
más fuerte porque es sobrepeso hay que
tener cuidado ya tenemos unos kilitos de
más pero sobre todo lo más importante es
cuidar esto del 30 en adelante
se categoriza como obesidad realmente
esto es la obesidad es una categoría en
la cual los nutriólogos y los no él y
los doctores nos clasifican de acuerdo a
nuestro peso en nuestra altura
mi índice de masa corporal está en 22
así es que caigo dentro de la zona de
salud y entonces si puedo estar muy
contenta bueno ahora si yo quisiera
saber cuál es el peso que requeriría
para estar en sobrepeso u obesidad vamos
a hacer lo siguiente sabemos que índice
de masa corporal es igual al peso sobre
altura al cuadrado así es que vamos a
despejar el peso por lo que índice de
masa corporal por altura al cuadrado es
igual al peso que requerimos para llegar
a ese a esa clasificación sabiendo que
el 25 que a partir de 25 es sobrepeso
vamos a hacer lo siguiente
multiplicaremos el 25 del índice de masa
corporal por el 2.56 correspondiente a
mi altura al cuadrado digamos que no
cambia mi altura que me mantengo en la
misma en la misma altura es igual a 64
kilos a partir de 64 kilos yo estaré
dentro del sobrepeso
si quiero calcular la obesidad ahora
multiplicar el 30 del índice de masa
corporal por 56 y me indica que ocupo
76.8 kilogramos
para estar dentro de los rangos de
obesidad